and now Great Moments in unintended
Consequences part one net benefits the
year 2012 the problem birds are
congregating on the Texas Medical Center
campus and doing
bird things the solution attach Nets to
the large oak trees on campus forcing
Birds to take their business elsewhere
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong turns out birds eat bugs with the
birds gone the trees became a Haven for
cute furry looking Critters that happen
to be North America's most venomous
caterpillar contact with these toxic
misery Tribbles can cause intense
radiating pain vomiting fever
convulsions paralysis and even death
with netsup and apex predators gone
researchers determine the population of
these comb over paint Merchants
increased by a whopping 7 300 percent
bad news for anyone but especially a
vulnerable population seeking health
care it's say oh I don't know a medical
center campus but you know what they say
flock around and find out part two prop
comedy the year 1986 the problem toxins
in California the solution Proposition
65 a ballot initiative which included a
provision making it illegal for
businesses to expose individuals to
chemicals known to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity without first
giving clear and reasonable warning
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong with the warning requirements were
established in 1988 235 chemicals made
the cut today there are over 900
compounds on The Proposition 65 list
including alcoholic drinks salted fish
Chinese style and wood dust even cocaine
is on the list so if your eight ball
doesn't have a warning label your dealer
is breaking the law with penalties for
non-compliance including fines of up to
twenty five hundred dollars per
violation per day and overzealous
litigators looking for their cut
business owners came to the rational
conclusion that the cost of a label was
less than the cost of litigation the
result morning labels everywhere
regardless of the severity of risk or
degree of exposure in bars restaurants
hotels spas ski resorts schools and
Disneyland on golf clubs lamps toasters
kids toys sunglasses potato chips
pancakes pumpkin puree and even trees
these signs have become so common that
one study found Californians have
learned to Simply ignore them but we
don't want to get sued either so warning
this video contains information on Prop
65 known to the state of California to
cause ambiguity between things that are
dangerous and things that are harmless
for more information go to holy crap
this is really not working out the way
we had planned.ca.gov part three Cold
Hard Cash the year 2005. the problem
greenhouse gases are destroying the
planet the solution a system devised by
the UN intergovernmental panel on
climate change which rewards companies
disposing polluting gases with carbon
credits which can later be turned into
Cash the more harmful the gas being
disposed the more credits were rewarded
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong hydrofluorocarbon 20 3 a
manufacturing byproduct of the common
coolant
hydrochlorofluorocarbon 22 was seen as
particularly harmful allowing a large
number of credits when destroyed so
manufacturers predominantly in India and
China ramped up production of the
coolant creating more of the dangerous
by-product which they immediately
destroyed A system that netted the
manufacturers tens of millions of
dollars a year some producers made twice
as much from the tax credit than sales
of the actual refrigerant increased
manufacturing of the coolant itself a
contributor of global warming kept the
market price competitively low
discouraging air conditioning and
refrigeration companies from switching
to less harmful Alternatives when the UN
announced the plan to stop the scheme
Chinese producers threatened to vent
their huge stockpile of gas directly
into the atmosphere but some activists
labeled environmental extortion nice
climate you've got there Great Moments
in unintended consequences good
intentions bad results do you know a
great moment in unintended consequences
put it in the comments
it already covered it there are 12 of
these now